all right so you guys heard me gosh over
Kung Fu Panda you know that I love the
movie and the visuals and the jokes and
the characters and so forth
so that's putting a lot of pressure on
its sequel Kung Fu Panda 2 and what I
think of that
honestly it's even better than the first
that's right I think this one is not
only as great as the original but it
surpasses it I think the first one
already set the bar pretty high it ups
the jokes it ups the action it ups the
characters it even ups the drama yeah
there's some real tearjerker scenes in
this movie yeah I know from Kung Fu
Panda 2 God these movies are so never
judge a book by it's cover PO returns as
the Dragon Warrior but a new threat has
entered town a peacock played by Gary
Oldman threatens the land with a brand
new weapon and he has a particular
interest in wiping out all the pandas
why because a prophecy foretold that a
panda is the only thing that will
destroy him he wants to take back the
land that he says is rightfully his so
Po and the fearsome five go to fight him
off but discover not only does he have a
greater army than they expected but they
also figure out the secret of Poe's
backstory and the reveal of his parents
rather than just tell the same story in
the first one or rehash anything they
actually decide to continue the story
like a good sequel should PO is not only
learning more as a person based also
learning more in his technique and the
fearsome five aren't just making fun of
them anymore they actually legitimately
respect him I even think there's a very
good real believable friendship between
him and tigress and again all the
techniques have a very heavy lean
towards actual martial arts philosophy
and ethics this one leaning towards
learning to conquer yourself before you
conquer your enemy remember how I said
in the first film the villain was a
little weak this one is the exact
opposite this is a great villain he has
a fantastic backstory he has a great
design he has a devious voice but they
still manage to get some good comedy out
of him to die envisioned is a little to
the left
but with the weapon by myself at little
bit board it's a perfect balance there's
also new characters played by Michelle
Yao jean-claude Van Damme and even the
return of old favorites like Dustin
Hoffman the film is great too in that I
didn't really know where was going at
least not the whole time I liked the
first one a lot but you could pretty
much tell what direction it was leaning
towards this one threw in a few more
twists and turns and made it a little
bit more dramatic
hell I'd you heard people crying at some
scenes in this movie yes
Kung Fu Panda 2 starring Jack Black
actually made people cry in the cinema
that's a damn impressive feat be honest
I have no problems with this movie at
all I think it's another one of those
perfect films everything has been
stepped up to the next level the action
that characters the story the visuals
and of course a great villain however is
there a downside yes there is it came
out the same weekend as fucking hangover
2 so everyone went to see the same
rehash bullshit that wasn't even really
that funny in the first one instead of
seeing this really funny really smart
artistically put together film
and what everybody say about the
hangover 2 yeah it sucked it was just
hangover 1 again what everyone say about
Kung Fu Panda 2 that was good it wasn't
just Kung Fu Panda again but no everyone
wants to see hangover 2 and yeah fuck
that movie if they don't make a Kung Fu
Panda 3 because of this I will be really
pissed off and the end indicates that
there's going to be a sequel and by god
with two films this good already under
their belt they better fucking make it I
don't even know what else to say without
giving away too much I just adored it
it's a film series that just keeps
getting better and better and I pray it
continues to do exactly that
if you liked the first one then you're
definitely gonna love the second
you